welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for a presentation
titled multiple myeloma screening past
present and the future it is my pleasure
to introduce to you
professor kareem azam assistant
professor
cancer biology division department of
radiation oncology
school of medicine washington university
in st
louis the research in professor azov's
lab
has a multi-disciplinary translational
approach involving cancer biology
immunotherapy tissue engineering and
drug delivery
he has a special interest in tumor
biomarkers
tumor microenvironment drug resistance
and metastasis and hematologic
malignancies
particularly in multiple myeloma
he also focuses on the development of ex
vivo 3d tissue engineered
cancer models for drug development and
personalized medicine
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen now if any
questions arise during the presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box
our speaker will address your questions
following the presentation
please join me in welcoming professor
zob i will now turn the presentation
over to him professor azov you may now
begin
your presentation
so thank you christy for this nice
introduction uh and i'm
honored and happy to be here and giving
this uh presentation
uh the titles my presentation will be
multiple myeloma screening
past present and future
for disclosures one the support of this
program is provided by abbott
and the information presented is based
on
my interpretation of the evidence and
the clinical experience
multiple myeloma is a cancer of plasma
cells
and plasma cells are very differentiated
b cells
they're the end of differentiation of b
cells and they are responsible
for fighting invading exogenous
materials like bacteria and viruses by
secretion
of antibodies to the system
the problem that when these become
malignant they over
occupy our bone marrow and
have a lot of side effects and a lot of
problems that cause in the end to death
part of that process is causing
low blood counts because the myeloma
cells just push away
all the other normal cells in the bone
marrow and we have
also a lot of bone destruction we get a
lot of bone fractures in these patients
due to bone destruction and also
a lot of infections because we have our
immune system suppressed
and finally a lot of patients die of
kidney problems mainly kidney failure
because of the huge amounts of
non-functional antibodies secreted
into the blood that the kidney needs to
take care of
currently if we look at the statistics
of multiple myeloma over the last 30
years
we see a small increase of the
prevalence of cases
and despite all the new wonderful
treatments that we have been seeing in
the last 10 years or so
we didn't really see a lot of decrease
in the number of deaths which is a
little frustrating but
soon we will probably explain why or try
to explain why
so looking here at the last it's almost
stable for the over
the last 30 years which means that there
is something fundamental that we don't
really
understand or maybe not even in the
treatment
or in the in the diagnosis of myeloma
so if we wanted just to look at how my
multiple myeloma is diagnosed right now
so there are the standard lab tests
that like blood counts blood chemistry
levels and album levels but we also
have some specific tests which are the
globaling the immunoglobulin levels
and these are because as we said before
the myeloma cells are
specialized in secreting immunoglobulins
so the cancer of these cells will start
secreting
a ton of immunoglobulins into the blood
so we can detect these
or fragments of them in the blood and
this will be an indication
that myeloma is occurring same thing we
can also detect them in the urine
especially the fragments of these
antibodies if we detect them in the
urine
then that means that there is a myeloma
going on
however these are more like
global tests that look at the entire
body at the same time
to go a little more specific and a
little more deep into the tissue level
we have imaging approaches like x-ray
that ct mri you know the standard
imaging uh
strategies and this would be more in the
organ level
where we see which parts of the body
there is uh involvement of multiple
myeloma
which is mainly in the bones around the
body
however these will not tell us any
cellular level
uh information and for this
we take bone marrow biopsies
so we take a bone marrow biopsy or an
aspirate
and we examine the aspirate on a
cellular level
so we look at the appearance of the
cells the shape of the cells
and how they are arranged in the bone
marrow and we can also
do some molecular stuff on them for
example we do fish
fluorescent inside of hybridization
which tells us more about
the dna structure and the dna content of
the cells if they have fragments if they
have multiplications and things like
that
we look at immunohistochemistry which
tells us
about the cells and how they look like
but these two the problem that they are
more qualitative than quantitative
and to do more quantitative analysis
we have two ways one is flow cytometry
where we take cells and we stain them
with antibodies
and we analyze the bone marrow
including the multiple myeloma cells for
expression of different markers
then we learn quantitatively about the
amount of multiple myeloma
and the cellular nature of the multiple
myeloma
cells in addition we can do cytogenetics
mainly next generation sequencing to
learn
about the genetics of the multiple
myeloma
cell clones and if we want to look at
these two which are
pretty powerful and compare them kind of
head to head
so they are both quantitative they are
both
sensitive the next generation sequencing
will
tell us about the clonogenicity or which
genetic clones are there
so that's really a plus while flow
cytometry cannot do that
however this one the next gen sequencing
needs a baseline sample all the time
so to compare it to through the
progression
while flow cytometry doesn't which is
actually a plus
for flow cytometry technically
the next generation sequencing is
is an available service commercially
however it's not available in most
hospitals and it's not available in most
academic
institutions so you need to send that
out to outsource it to companies
to do that while flow cytometry is
wide available everywhere almost in
every hematology clinical or research
lab
in universities in hospitals and
everywhere
so that's a plus for flow cytometry as
of complexity
you know the machines and the
bioinformatics needed for next gene
sequencing is much more complicated and
expensive
for flow cytometry it's pretty simple
all what you need
is standard software and for the
turnaround which sometimes very
important especially in relapsed
patients
for next gen sequencing we need about
two weeks
while the flow cytometry you get the
results in three four hours
that's again a huge advantage for flow
cytometry
and the cost the cost per sample for
an ngs is about a thousand five hundred
dollars per sample
while for flow it's three hundred
dollars so there is kind of a clear
advantage
for flow cytometry over next-gen
sequencing
a lot of people would agree with me some
people will not
but at least from technical point of
view
flow cytometry is easier and more
available
so currently there are three markers
to identify myeloma cells by flow
cytometry
and i'll start from the bottom up
so we start with cd45 which is a pan
leukocyte marker it just identifies all
white blood cells
cd45 is a surface adhesion molecule
and then we have to complex it to
add another layer of specificity we look
at cd38 which is a pan
lymphocyte marker which is expressed on
b
cells these cells in case and some other
melody cells
but it's now a little more focused
towards the myeloma and it's generally
highly expressed in myeloma too
and the third marker which is the gold
standard for detecting myeloma currently
is cd138 which is also another adhesion
molecule
but it's specific very specific for
plasma cells
so if you notice these are all
cell adhesion molecules and
they are mediating the interaction
between multiple myeloma and the tumor
microenvironment
and we have been studying the cell cell
adhesion
between myeloma and its tumor micro
environment intensively over the last 10
years
we now understand the cellular processes
behind that
and the cell signaling and if
if we will have to go deeper in that i'm
more than happy to do so later
but it's it's not the main focus of this
uh presentation
but what i wanted to emphasize that this
interaction
is very important for the development
progression and and dissemination of
multiple myeloma
and now we in our lab we have
characterized that very deeply and we
understand it very well
and what's the role of each of these
molecules
in the process of progression
one important feature of the multiple
myeloma tumor micro environment
is hypoxia we found that
the more progressed is the tumor
there is more tumor hypoxia hypoxia is
the lack of oxygen
and it happens because the progression
rate of myeloma
out rates the progress the development
of
blood vessels so we will have more tumor
than what the body could supply blood
vessels to it
so the tumors become hypoxic now
what what why is that important we found
that actually this changes dramatically
the properties of the multiple myeloma
cell
they become much more aggressive they
become much more metastatic
they start going to new places
through aggress from the primary side
to the blood and homing to new sites
in addition it makes it make way much
more drug resistant
the hypoxic cells are less going cell
cycle
so they become more resistant to
chemotherapy
and they display stem cell-like features
meaning they are dormant but when given
the opportunity
they will start growing so fast
and making the relapse of the patient
but how was all that related when we
looked at the effect of hypoxia on the
expression of cd138 which is
the gold standard marker for detection
of multiple myeloma
we found actually that this marker that
has been used now for decades to detect
multiple myeloma
is lost from the surface of these cells
so we now know that there's
a portion of multiple myeloma cells
which are hypoxic we know they are there
that they are actually not displaying
the main marker that people are looking
for
when we are looking for multiple myeloma
cells
so we looked at
the effect of hypoxia and if you can see
here
the effect on cd 38 and 138
in the right uh box and we found that
while the expression of cd 38 didn't
change that much
the effect of cd 138 went down
dramatically almost to less than half
so therefore we learned that to detect
multiple myeloma we need to develop a
strategy
that's not relying it's not dependent on
cd138
and why is that because it is specific
for plasma cells that's right
but it's variable expression so you
cannot rely on it to detect
all the cells there cd45
is also variable with hypoxia also
although i didn't show it but it is
variable with hypoxia it changes
and it's also widely widely expressed on
all leukocytes so it doesn't really give
us
any specificity the only marker left
is the cd38 however
it's not very specific to multiple
myeloma
it's very highly expressed on myeloma
cells it doesn't change with hypoxia
but it's also expressed on other cells
like b cells t
cells in case not to the same extent not
to the same
level it is expressed in myeloma but
still it's present so the
idea our idea was let's use this
kind of unspecific marker and make it
more specific how can we make it more
specific
simply by excluding all the others
for example we will stain for cd38
we know we will be picking now all
myeloma cells
the cd138 positive and the cd3138
negative which are in the uh black
uh oval here but we will also be picking
others like t cells b cells
and k cells etc so we will add
antibodies to stain these specifically
and exclude them from the total group so
we add cd3
to remove t cells we add cd19 to take
out
b cells to uh take in case we add cd16
and etc so we have a line of
exclusion markers what we call cd3 cd 14
cd 16 19 and 123
this will ensure when we add them
to the mix we will ensure that we can
exclude
all the cells which are not myeloma but
still cd
38 positive now we put
all these exclusion marker in one
channel in the flow cytometry
for example in the 5c channel but it
doesn't have to be
and we put the 38 which is the positive
marker
on another channel like the apc but we
also it doesn't also have to be it can
be any other color
so the idea here is that the multiple
myeloma cell
will be 38 positive but negative for
for all the others regardless if
it's 138 positive or 138
negative and we will i'll show you in a
minute
how this will actually start picking
more myeloma cells which the classic
gold standard marker cd138
will not fit what we started with here
was that we combined
normal bone marrow cells that they don't
have myeloma
we combine these with a myeloma cell
line
we added exactly 10 percent cells into
the normal
bone marrow cells and once we added
normal or neuromoxic myeloma cells or we
added myeloma cells which were
put in hypoxia before the combination
then we tried to find them back either
with cd138 which is the cold standard
or with cd 38 alone without the
exclusion or with the new method
so when we try to find with 138
we get in the normoxic cells
we get about seven percent out of the
ten
we get less than five percent if the
cells were hypoxic
which actually means that half of the
cells that we put
if they would be hypoxic we wouldn't
even detect them
using the gold standard model
if we just use cd 38 alone we are
picking now 25
instead of 10 because we are picking
other cells
not only myeloma but when we use the new
method
that we just defined we pick back
exactly 10 which is what we put to start
with
so we took that and we took it a little
further
in vivo and
we uh put myeloma cells gfp labeled
green fluorescence protein label so we
could track them
and we put them in mice in skid mice
in different amounts and we let them
grow for almost three weeks
so we got mice with different levels
of myeloma involvement in their bone
marrow
we take the bone marrow out just like we
do in patients we take a bone marrow
biopsy or a bone marrow aspirate
so we isolated bone marrow from these
mice
and we we compared how much we can
detect myeloma cells
in the marrow using gfp
which is actually an artificial color
that we put
so every cell that we that's gfp is
by definition myeloma then we try to see
if we could find these using the gold
standard marker and as you see
in the right part despite that the
amount of gfp
slash myeloma cells was increasing
dramatically
out up to 65 percent in the in the bone
marrow
the cd 138 could barely detect
10 so this is a huge false negative
while if we look at the new method we
picked
exactly the same amount that the gfp
found this gives us another layer of
confidence
that now we are not missing any myeloma
cell
but even more importantly we are not
picking
any false positive so we took that
and we wanted to validate another layer
in patients so we took patient bone
marrow aspirates
and we looked first of all at cd 138
positive and negative we just took the
138
negative portion which is supposed to be
no myeloma cells according to the
classic definition
we detected with the new method
so we isolated the apc positive
fitsy negative as we defined it before
and we looked at the clonality so
myeloma cells when there is myeloma
there's actually um the cells
detected there are always clonal
it means this they either secrete
copper antibodies or lambda antibodies
because generally it starts from one
clone so that's another way to make sure
that
we have a clonal disease by
identifying if it was kappa or lambda
and when we looked
at for example this patient we found
that
about 99 of the cells that we detected
with the new model
where all kappa
now in normal case it will be about half
and half
it can be a little more or a little less
in a normal subject
but generally the mile the plasma the
normal plasma cells distribution
will be almost half and half but when
you find
99 of the cells kappa
which is one of them it means that these
are
clonal these are cancer so we did that
for a cohort of patients
of 20 patients and we found
that the marrow of these patients would
include sometimes
up to 35 percent cells
which are myeloma according to our
definition
but they are cd138 negative
and when we look at the clonality of
these patients
actually they show significant clonality
it means they are not innocent plasma
cells
these are clonal cancer plasma cells
which by the regular tests will be
defined
as normal cells or just missed
the regular classic model
based on cd138 wouldn't even
detect them we looked
just to make sure that these cells are
very clonal
we looked at how much nonclonal the
percentile in these
cells detected we found that these all
were less than one percent
nonclonal so all of these cells are
highly clonal meaning highly cancerous
therefore this tells us that we have
developed now
a new model that actually
can detect a new subset of myeloma that
was
completely missed before and
if you look at these cells these become
very important in the definition of what
we call minimal residual disease
so minimal residual disease refers to
myeloma cells
that are present in the bone marrow
that after we treat them clinically
they're they stay there
they're almost undetected
and they induce remission after
remission they induce
relapse so how that works
what's the concept so if we treat and we
bring
the the tumor burden let's say
10 times lower so we will have a
kind of short period of remission if we
make the tumor burden a hundred times
lower
we will have a longer emission and so on
until we get almost to no cells
which will will say no remission
that's probably theoretical most of the
time we get to like
10 100 cells if we are really lucky
then we have long periods of remission
so that these minimum amounts of cells
are very hard to detect you know why
because
as i said before most likely these cells
are drug resistant are the very hypoxic
ones
which are actually cd138
negative so
it's now known that the definition of
mrd will change how we treat because
it's not
enough to just reduce the size of the
tumor
we want to bring it to a level that's
even these minimal residual disease will
be gone
however how to detect these with
what's the optimal technology is exactly
the question
so we suggested using this flow
cytometry technique that we developed
to detect minimal residual disease
because it's it's again
independent of cd138 and we tried
to find a connection between the amount
of cells that we found
in the bone marrow using our technology
with the time
takes the patient to relapse
so we took a group of patients
after treatment they were defined cured
they were defined cr and we looked
into them with their bone marrow using
the new technology or using
cd 138 the standard uh model
so with cd 138 they all looked
pretty pretty clean less than half
percent if you look at the left
box and there is no difference
we couldn't really find any difference
in um the amount of cd 138 cells
in patients who relapsed fast less than
24
months or in patients who relapsed
slow or longer but when we look
at the bone marrow with our new method
we found that those who relapsed
fast actually have
pretty high amount more than three
percent
of the undetected cells using the
classic techniques
now we found about three percent while
the ones
who relapsed late or had a slower
relapse
had less than one percent detected using
the new method
so now we could correlate between the
mrd minimal residual disease
detected by our technology compared
to the classic technology and that we
correlate with time to progression
or relapse while the classic mrd
fails to do that so
in our case for example i would go and
recommend
the clinicians to continue the treatment
for those
who has uh who have a lot of uh
myeloma cells left like three percent
two percent
and to bring this even further down to
deepen
their uh uh um uh
response to therapy and make them
relapse much later
from here we wanted to go a little
um more exotic i would say
and we thought could we instead of bone
marrow biopsy in patients
could we detect these cells in the blood
and currently
there is no way to correlate
or to find almost any circulating
myeloma cells
although in in vivo models we do see
them
but we cannot find them in patients and
the reason
is because the circulating cells as we
have shown
are very hypoxic so most likely these do
not have
any cd38 and when we looked in animals
actually we looked at gfp cells again so
we know these were circulating
but when we tried to find them with
cd138 if you look at the
right box we found nothing
because these circulating gfp cells
myeloma cells
are not expressing any 138 it's lost
but with the new model we actually
detected
about 80 percent i would say in some of
them we
we detected almost 100 of the
circulating cells
so with this method we could
somehow skip bone marrow biopsy which is
a
very expensive and very painful
procedure
by just taking blood from these patients
and detecting with the right markers
we did that in patients and we
actually did find a lot of circulating
cells
in the patients while with cd138 we
found
again nothing less than 0.5
so we are we tried also to
look at if we can predict uh
progression-free survival
and see if that correlates we did find a
correlation
not as strong statistically as before
but it's statistically significant
it's highly statistical significance so
in patients
who had a fast relapse
we found a high amount of circulating
myeloma cells
while the ones who relapsed later
we found lower amounts of the
circulating cells
so just in the end to compare all the
three
uh technologies that we have available
right now
so we have next-gen sequencing it's
um quantitative and highly quantitative
for detection of mrd
it is while the cd138
is not that good for detection of 138
our new markers are highly quantitative
prediction of a progression-free
survival
it is right with next-gen sequencing
not with flaw cytometry based on cd138
but yes for our markers
time of analysis for next-gen sequencing
as we said it's one to two weeks
in our in all in both flow techniques
it's two to three hours
availability of the service for next-gen
sequencing we need to outsource
the flow is in every lab and
sample preparation no primers
so we need primers and we need reference
samples for next-gen sequencing
no such requirements are needed for flow
detection of circulating tumor cells
it has never been shown yet by next
generation sequencing i'm sure
that at some point people will start
exploring that
it's poor in uh cd 138 based flow
we can detect it with our new technology
using flow cytometry
so that's a huge advantage and the cost
is pretty low
for both the flow techniques and the
cd138 so i think the future
is going to be something close to the
technology that we developed
and at that point i will uh thank you
for uh listening and i uh
would like to open it for questions
thank you professor azab for that
outstanding presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of our webinar
now as a reminder to our audience please
submit your questions via the q a box
okay professor azab here's our first
question
although cd 138 is considered the gold
standard marker for myeloma
as you mentioned and others have also
shown that it is shed
from the cell surface in some mm
populations
can you elaborate more on what the mm
cells lose
their cd138 surface expression
sure um i mentioned before
uh cd 138 is an adhesion molecule
it interacts with integrands uh to uh
promote cell cell adhesion but we found
that the expression of this surface
marker is actually reduced
due to many stresses and
probably tumor hypoxia is the most
important one of them but it's not the
only one
for example treatment with chemotherapy
would even reduce it
even lower so if you think about these
myeloma patients that were heavily
treated with chemotherapy
and the cells are hypoxic and drug
resistant and have cd 138 low
now we treat them with more chemotherapy
and they even
lose even more the cd-138 expression
therefore now these cells will become
almost
unseen in the patients so
we will observe their occurrence
because of these cells actually in most
of 90 of the patients because we miss
these cells
in more than 90 percent of the patients
thank you our next question there have
been several attempts to develop
cd 138 independent markers for myeloma
how is this new method different
right yeah i i agree you know the uh
especially
uh there is uh um
a lot of research on that especially
coming from europe
and um the methods that are now used
uh are really complex they call them
as of their complexity they call them
next-gen
uh fluorocytometry because uh it's based
on
uh 9 to 8 color flow
which makes it technically very complex
and hard
you will need special machines to do
that special flow cytometry machines
and you will need very highly skilled
technicians or workers to do it now in
research setting this might work
in clinical setting this will be very
hard to implement
the great advantage of this technology
that it relies on two colors
one color is positive one color is
negative as
as simple as that and as of
instrumentation actually these machines
are available in
every single hematology level in clinic
or or in uh in research we
you could even very easily do high
throughput because it simply
just two colors yes and no and that's it
that's what i think is the huge
advantage of the new technology
great thank you for that explanation our
next question
could you please elaborate more about
replacing
bone marrow biopsy with blood analysis
for detection of mrd
this sounds like a winner but seems like
we're not quite there yet
it is it is i agree um we're starting
um the point is that for long long time
you know our group and many other groups
we were
having very hard time finding any
circulating myeloma cells
at all and now we know the reason why
because these cells are hypoxic they
just lose their cd138
on the way to the new metastatic side
so with this new technology now at least
we can see them
now if this is going to replace bone
marrow biopsy or not
that's definitely a bigger question we
might need
much more research to to to prove that
especially in the mrd
setting where we know that just a little
bit of the myeloma cells actually
circulate
even when it's a full-blown disease so
in mrd settings
it's probably hard to rely on blood
samples
but i would so we will have to still go
to bone marrow bypasses
but for i would say routine detection
and routine
um uh looking at tumor progression or
just
diagnosis of the disease i would be i
would feel very comfortable using the
circulating uh technology
okay well thank you and we have time for
one more question
technically speaking how do you see
these markers
being marketed
okay so that's that's a good question
actually
so um the idea here is that we take
these markers as a kit it's actually a
bunch of antibodies
that we put them all together in
in in a vial so the way we use it right
now we
we very much use this technology to
detect myeloma cells
in 3d cultures and in vivo and the
reason
is that in 3d cultures and in vivo there
are they develop
hypoxic conditions and a lot of these
cells really lose their cd-138
so to go and detect them with the
classic models
it's useless so what we do actually is
we have a vial
that we mix all the antibodies together
and we just take the same amount and add
it to the different myeloma
samples so to to answer your question
directly
i would think of it as a kit
that has a mix of antibodies that will
be
sold as a vial that the researcher would
take
a certain amount per certain amount of
cells that you want to detect myeloma in
and just analyze it directly by flow i i
would even call it
multiple myeloma detection kit
exciting very easy upscale
it seems so well professor kareem azam
thank you so much for your time today
and for your research and we want to
thank our audience too for their
outstanding questions we hope they found
today's
presentation to be informational and
insightful
now today's presentation will be
available for on-demand viewing
and to our audience don't miss out on
the other valuable presentations on our
agenda
you can visit that agenda tab in the
auditorium for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
and until next time
goodbye